greetings from podcastville it's
wednesday
the 21st of april i hope you had a nice
4 20.
i hope everybody's all right nobody
[__] you know
dose you with nothing but anyway the
joint is brought to you by
manscape let me ask you something [__]
oh you yeah you
you got a bush down there if your ass is
so hairy it looks like bob ross
you're living in your [__] pants
making paintings down there
[__] those little [__] clouds be like
your uncle joey my balls are clean
and [__] beautiful no hippie [__]
here no patchouli juice
and i blame it on one person thanks to
manscape even at 58
they make my nutsac look [__]
tremendous okay
with the [__] lawnmower 3.0 the best
trimmer known to [__] man
i just hold on to my [__] dick and
even in the
dark i could do it and feel confident
and feel like i'm not going to chop my
[__] dick off
because that's a man's biggest [__]
fear that's why we didn't trim before
because everybody's scared that you
might nip your [__] dick and you got
to walk around with a [__] up looking
dick
but not with lomo not with manscaped
this is three
[__] generations they got science
working on your [__] nuts
this is the only ball trimmer with
advanced skin safe technology
that won't nick or snag your nut sack or
the skin around your [__] helmet
you momos you can't cut your dick off
with this thing even if you [__]
tried
you could [__] put it on your dick
and nothing will happen but wait there's
more
they caught the crop preserver they
caught the crop revival they got the
ball mop
[__] wipes right in front of you
there listen i got the preserver
but i'm fine i got the ball wipe so i'm
all out of [__] revival because i'm
my balls look [__] up so i got to
revive them from time to time and
you got to clean out your stinky little
[__] covert nose hairs
with the weed whacker you saw what
happened when you don't clean your nose
a [__] snot comes out
it looks like another [__] baby's
coming out of your nose and now you can
smell
good as your balls with that cologne
refined
trust me i've been using that too
because gentlemen prefer
smooth balls that smell good like uncle
[__] joey so get in all
with [__] manscape get the
performance package you get the nose
trimmer
you get the [__] lawnmower you get
the crop reviver
you get the crop [__] preserver and
you'll be
tip top [__] magoo but it
starts today
right now get 20 percent off and free
shipping at manscape.com
joey that's manscape.com
joey 20 off and free shipping and your
dick and your nut sack
will look tip top magoo women will be
calling you going you got the best
looking dick and time
when you use manscape.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
one of my favorites
we've all been in a lockdown for almost
a year and i think i've seen
everything on netflix by now but with
expressvpn
you could trick the computer into
thinking you're a different [__]
country and you'll be able to watch
anything in the [__] world and you
already know
that a vpn will protect your privacy
online but it's
it's taken my tv watching to the next
[__] level
my wife loves all this [__] she unlocks
movies from england
and tv shows are only available in other
countries and it works on any service
in over 100 countries netflix amazon
youtube bbc
you name it there's some stuff there's
some dark stuff
on the [__] internet that you want to
watch i won't even talk about it
and expressvpn will get you there it's
ex
it's ridiculously fast and it streams in
hd
and it's got no buffering and it works
for every person and device in your home
and it's easy as pie to use even with a
guy like me
just push one button and change your
location
you're watching rick and morty in
[__] france you understand me
you see what i'm trying to say to you
use my special link right now
expressvpn.com
joey and you can get an extra three
months for free free
free free support to join watch what you
want
and protect your privacy with
expressvpn.com
joey let's get this [__] party
started
it's a beautiful [__] wednesday some
years i hung off from 4
20. let's do this [__] [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here wednesday the 21st
[__] tremendous 4 20. i hope you
[__] had a great time
[__] weeks of smoking some be real
weed
tremendous a little mr green thumb
action
give us your love but it's a beautiful
day to be alive today
i want to talk to you about some we have
a guest today a special guest
who i love to death this guy uh opened
up a lot of doors for me but before we
get to it
i want to talk to you guys about
something um
when i got to la it was 1997.
i got thrown a pilot and
i didn't know what the [__] i was doing
you know
and uh then i
got the movie baseball and i had no
[__] idea what i was doing
and i was ashamed i was embarrassed i
was movie buff
when they called me and they said that i
had made it into baseball i was like
what are you [__] serious because i
it was so bad you know it was it was
horrible when i got the pilot for cbs
when i first when i first got the pilot
for cbs bronx tale
bronx county bronx tale i'm sorry bronx
county
um i really had like seven scenes i'm
not gonna lie to anybody
my acting was so [__] atrocious like
how can you not act you're a comic my
acting
was so [__] atrocious that by the
time we shot the pilot
i think i had a line if i
if it i mean i mean they cut everything
down i mean i
it was it was you know and i'm i'm
listen this is the truth this is what
happens when
you go into something not knowing
something that i wasn't used to doing
i always before you know even with the
guitar whether it's jiu-jitsu
i want you know when i lift weights i
know i don't know everything
you know my job i'm a professional
[__] comedian
everything else i don't know about you
know but when you get to l.a
at first your manager just says hey do
you want to go out for an audition and
you're like
i guess so everybody else is doing it it
seems like the right [__] thing to do
i was always listen i was a bigger fan
growing up of movies
than what i was a stand-up i'm not gonna
lie to you richard pryor with his albums
i
loved the early richard pryor stuff and
that's what i held onto and that's what
i used when i started
you know a little bit of the early prior
and that's why i talked about the
subjects i talked about
but i was more of a [__] movie guy
than a stand-up comedy guy i i loved
[__] movies and but then i saw easy
money and i knew that rodney was a
stand-up and then i
i saw the toy and all the richard
pryor's movies and i'm like [__]
they do movies you know blue streak with
[__] gene wilder
richard pryor did some great [__]
movies so that was my
whole thing and then i knew that rick
dukeman did movies so when i got to la
you know people were like you gotta go
on audition and stuff like that so i
just went
you know maybe i was too proud to
ask for help people would say you want
to run lines and i would run lines with
people
but years later i was running lines with
people who were bums that they couldn't
book a [__] headshot themselves
so why was i running lines with them do
you know what i'm saying like i was
running lines with losers
you know so how am i gonna book if i'm
hanging out with [__] a bum
so
sorry about that i'm a little [__]
dehydrated so
i didn't really know much about it but i
was too scared to [__] ask
but after the uh basketball debacle
there was an acting classic you know dab
the big time acting classes in la
that you could join guys look at it's
like
buying gasoline you know when you go
like they want the super unleaded
super super super unleaded or whatever
acting is acting
you know most of the people that teach
acting
again can't book a [__] headshot
themselves
you know the p you know i mean that's
the truth most people have an acting
school
it's not you know james franco had a
[__] acting school you know i didn't
go to that one
you know and look he ended up [__]
molesting women i don't know what the
[__] he was doing over there
what's the other guy the guy from
[__] uh he was in in
death death wish and all that [__] i
forget
bloomberg eric greenberg whatever his
[__] name was he's like
he's like a real star he was in a couple
of big time movies he had an acting
school
and i heard it was a [__] joke over
there with women and [__] like that
so unless you know and then i met james
coburn years later and he's the one that
told me
to get out of acting class you had
natural instincts
but to make a long story short after my
debacle with [__]
basketball i was like i gotta figure
this [__] out
so yeah i went on the road i disappeared
i did two
[__] weird tours i disappeared and
then when i came back and settled in
in 99 right before i met [__] terry
i got into an acting class and while i
met terry in the beginning like if i
my anniversary's 4th of july with terry
i think by
august of 2000 i had forced myself
into an acting class and this time it
was a a
a big-time one so i could really be
prepared i had gone to like this guy
frank something on schrader he had like
an actor's
core but he didn't like stand-up comics
it was monday nights
from seven to nine i always had to leave
because i always had a spot at the
improv
or latino night at the lab factory so i
always had to leave
so he would get pissed off at me they
were cheap acting classes
so i learned the basics the guy that
really really taught me how to [__]
lay
it down was i had a black acting coach a
little african-american gay guy
i had this little acting class on
saturday mornings i found out it was
dropping it was like 20
droppings and i started he was over by
gower by uh
waffles and chicken over there they had
these little huts
off of hollywood between hollywood and
sunset and
i really he really explained it to me
how to go like three acting teachers
before i [__] knew what the [__] they
were talking about and then once i went
to havana chubbic which is the cream of
the crop
acting in 2000 i started attending
seminars
i started going to casting directing
and i started [__] going uh you know
reading workshop co-reading workshops
and [__] like that
that were isolated like tuesdays at
seven o'clock i was in town
i would pay the 50 bucks just so i can
meet that casting director
but you know what it was all fine and
dandy and i was auditioning for
[__] but i wasn't booking anything and
then a show came on the air called the
[__] sopranos
and i happened to look like one of the
guys and my [__] life changed
you know by by the second by the
beginning of the second season of the
sopranos
for people who went through it and who
remember it which is 2001 and 2000
this the television system had become
everything
mobster i you know i can't count
i'm gonna you know i try to find my i
have movie call sheets
i have a couple of commercial call
sheets but
i don't have all my commercial clients i
have a lot of [__] movie call sheets
that i release from time to time on
patreon but
commercial call sheets i don't have i
could be
[__] i'm sure
conservatively from 2001
to 2003 or four i shot
let's just to be fair four commercials a
year
that you have i shot 12 commercials in
three years four years
that you people never saw never knew i
shot
from pennzoil to verizon cable
to [__] pepto-bismol to [__]
what's the die-hard battery for sears
i did all those commercials but they
were mob related
you know i'm doing nfps i talked about
this i'm doing
nfps pretty soon i'm going to
incorporate it with my patreon
i'm doing an nft of me and lee i'm doing
an nft of
there's different pictures that i have
throughout the years from the county
store
i'm gonna probably do 10 of them at 20
hours a piece
and then auction stuff off i have a new
idea the florentine crime family put it
into my head
i want to do the nfts and then i'll sell
them through patreon
and i'll pick one person every month
who wins the nft and they do a zoom
into the joint for 10 minutes which
they buy the nfp to of them doing the
zoom
person can buy it only one person can
buy it so we're gonna [__] start
[__] around with nfps here
but this isn't the point of this
conversation the point of this
conversation was that after the sopranos
came out
i have to thank them because
because of them i started working
constantly
constantly constantly and
it and it opened up a door for me
because i resembled somebody
that's my little secret that i shouldn't
tell you but i'm telling you
that the reason why i got started in
movies and acting
was because the sopranos blew up so when
i would go into these auditions i looked
so much like vincent pastor
that they would hire me for all those
commercials pennzoil
this night to the sears commercial that
was brilliant it was me and some other
chooch
[__] digging uh we got a guy in the
trunk and we're digging and we have the
headlights on
and we're digging we're digging we're
digging we put the chooch in the hole
and then we go start the car the
battery's dead
and it says die hard next time go to
sears and all this [__]
but what was happening was before the
commercials had
[__] the italian american
organization was cutting them down
going again you're insulting [__]
italian americans
so you didn't see my commercials i must
have shot like i said
12 commercials i know for a fact
pennzoil we put a guy in a trunk
and we open up and the camera's looking
at us uh
sears we had a guy in the trunk i still
got the picture of me
one of the nfts is me big digging the
trench in this [__] sears commercial
so i'm putting that out you know i
but what i'm trying to get to if it
wasn't for the sopranos
and it wasn't a venison pastor i
wouldn't have booked [__] so what did i
do
i called vincent pastor and i asked him
if he'd come on uncle joey's joint
and he said yes i hope you enjoy it it's
vinnie passed off for the next couple of
minutes enjoy it [__]
uncle vinnie it's my residual jacks
i don't owe you nothing [__] you
owe me money
[Laughter]
this is getting out of hand i'm not
taking none of your work
you're gonna have to grow a goatee to
catch up with me
i hear you you're always doing something
how are you vinnie
i i'm good you know are we on are we
taping already
yeah we're taping okay it's us until the
wheels fall off
and i love you and uh i'm sorry we
couldn't get together during these
bad times you know
you know because i was trying to do your
show earlier yes
yes yes it's been a nightmare but i was
trying to come to your acting class
two years ago no you're not coming to my
acting class
i have to you could zoom in as a guest
star
no not stop joey i'm inviting you right
now
you zoom in as a guest and you observe
and you talk to my students you're not
coming out as a student
let me tell you something why not i
always got something to learn
can't teach you how to hack you can't
teach man to play football
come on let me tell you something i knew
you were doing it with
uh miss vanzant about two years ago on
monday nights
and i had heard about it but i had to
work every monday so that's what was the
problem i didn't know how to get a hold
of you
yeah i don't know if you're still doing
it everything's on zoom now joey you
know
so i'm going to tell you what i'm going
to do i want your guys to email me
your email address done done afterwards
i'm going to link you
up with all these things and get you
involved with me and maureen at renegade
we'd love to have you there
yes i'd love to you know i'm always
listening listen
listen listen you need help on an
audition or something you we zoom in
each other at night
you know boom boom boom as long as
you're not taking it apart away from me
i'm not going to help you take a part
with me if you want to get involved with
renegade we just knocked off uh
streetcar named desire i directed this
thing on zoom it took us like nine
months to do
and we're gonna stream it uh at the end
of the month and that's the things we're
doing right now
until theater comes back i would love to
be a part of that man
oh i'm gonna tell her when i was joey
come on i would love i was talking about
it the other day i want to be
involved in some type of theater group i
didn't grow up in theater vinnie i grew
up on the streets i didn't do no theater
me too you know i didn't do no theater
so it's always been a dream of mine
no i was a club owner you know that yes
and how did you get into theater um
i started uh doing some community
theater
in the 70s but i when i started studying
i went to hb studios where i teach now
and i started taking classes
and then i studied with this guy tommy
and then we started putting plays
up we started doing on the waterfront we
did um
that's a good play for you we did
requiem for heavyweight lamppost
me and all my guys we started doing a
lot of plays and you know what it didn't
pay the bills joey
but it kept you sharp it's like training
to be a fighter
it keeps you sharp the rehearsals and
everything right right
right i was gonna do cuba i want to do
cuba and his teddy bear
i saw that i've been dying to do be a
part of that
you do the young role uh
yeah i think i would go for bert young's
role i would like
did you see that play or what how do you
know about
a friend of mine no had a a video of it
okay somebody had videoed it i had never
gone to theater at that time
yeah and i was blown away i was blown
away i went right to samuel french
and bought the play if i'm going to get
you involved
you'd be good you know what you'll be
good ass
pick up requiem for a heavy weight okay
and look at the anthony coin roll the
lead mount mcclintock you got
it be a great role for you just read it
and then say vinnie i read the play
okay um
uh rod sterling before was a movie it
was a play
it was a c for cbs playhouse jack plants
did it on television
wow and then they went to the movies and
they had anthony quinn
and um my guy jackie gleason well this
is good i didn't know you went to all of
this
so when did you start acting who's
interviewing you who gives a [__]
when did you start acting vinnie i was a
stand-up comic
i got i was in seattle and one night a
guy came up to me and he goes i work for
cbs
we're doing a play and you would be
perfect for the [__] play
i said fine i never took an acting class
nothing
a month later they flew me to la i did
some type of test
and they called me a week later and told
me i had the pilot
i never studied i never did i went to
the [__] movies
i came from cuba i lived on 205 west
88th street
and my godfather would walk me to times
square every saturday watch a different
movie
he took me to see the love bug the
world's greatest athlete then he pulled
me aside and he goes listen
we're going to go see adult movies no
more kid movies
you just don't tell your mother 40
seconds straight down like the 40
seconds oh
that's a story in the story [__] the
velocity papers was my first movie then
the majesty secret service yes so i went
to see those at the movie theater and
i'd love
movies but i never saw myself as an
actor then i moved
out you know what you got to do
um especially i've been doing a lot of
this during the pandemic i watched a lot
of the
turner classic movies absolutely and i
looked at a lot of garfield and george
raft
and emij robinson and
block nine you know um
ernest baldwin was a great character
you know you watch him do marty marty's
a good role for you
all these guys dj calm
those are the guys that you know i said
wow
you know i'm gonna tell you something
it's interesting i could talk to you
about this but
i didn't think i could be an actor until
they came out with the godfather
there's got a bunch of italians up there
working i said i guess maybe i could do
this
now when the godfather came out what
were you doing i was running nightclubs
into a show
i put a tape on in my room because i was
a dj
and i went up and i started midnight
godfather and i come back and nobody's
drinking
that you know it was like slow i put a
tape on and i went up there with the
boss and we saw the godfather at
midnight the first one
and i said to myself you know what you
could do this
and how long did it take you to get on
one godfather three
and i had a little bit with eli wallach
and i was showing my students i said see
you can't turn down extra work
you see look what they did to me coco
put me in the scene when he like wow
i don't look like no extra over there so
you don't know
you know and we all started somewhere
but i remember i met you on the grudge
match i was mad at you
well you were you you had a big
part come on no
but look let me tell you what happened i
moved with the nero
yes but did they talk to you about that
movie
no oh they they they it was like
the the director i had worked for him
before on the longest yard
and when the longest yard ended me and
him didn't
end in a good way i thought he didn't
like me he told me at the premiere
i wasn't his first choice for what for
the
longest yard well i was up for that that
you beat me out
well that because i'll tell you what
happened they told me they were looking
at you
and tony serragusa
who got it tony sarah goose are you no i
got it but they were looking at you
and sarah right and then i got [__] up
one night and i'm like how the [__]
no disrespect vinny but i'm a comic adam
is a comedian i go how they're gonna
give it to sarah goosa
or the vinny this can't happen so i went
to
[__] al's big and fat store in
houston texas
i got a little football helmet for a kid
i put it on my head
i got a size [__] small i was 418 at
the time
my stomach stuck out and i did a a video
of me catching a football running
and i looked at the italian guy that i
was going to cast in the movie
that uh i watched the original and i
just did his lines
you mean the original bert reynolds the
original with burt reynolds
so i took the guy tony that they were
actually i was replacing
and i took his lines and put it on
audition tape
and sent it in that's how i got that
movie holy who'd you send it to
i sent it right to adam sandler's office
they told me they were looking for a
star name you
or ceragusa i refuse to handle that
response yeah but nikki tutorial was in
that that was great i remember that
yes but um i was so proud of you i'm
serious when i saw you
in grudge match i met you at the
premiere
yo that was the first time we met we
hugged each other we're like you
it's you yeah right right right and uh a
lot of times
people post a picture of you and they
see it's me or they post a picture of me
and they say it's you
[__] hilarious you don't know how
many people i got
a thousand like while no sopranos was on
the air
and you were on the air yes i have
thousands of stories of when i would
come to
jersey to visit i thought it was you i
went to a shop right one day
and the manager bought my groceries you
guys
he thought it was you i i went into two
i went into a donut shop because i was
lost on the 34
it's like 10 miles from here from my
house now
i was lost on route 34 and i saw i saw a
donut shop and i saw two cop cars i
pulled in
and i went to one of the cops and i go
hey man i'm lost he looked at me
he thought it was me he thought it was
you
so the one cop got in front of me and
the one cop got behind me with their
lights on
and they made sure i got home okay so
you didn't say nothing so what the [__]
can i say something
you've been copycat me for a long time
now [__] you why would i say something
glad that we finally had this
confrontation
on your podcast to discuss this
because i i'm proud of you joey i love
you i want to work with you
i want to work with you too i've been
dying to work with you i've been dying
to find something
de niro when uh martin scorsese and that
leonardo caput are doing some movie
about flowers or something what's it
called
i don't know yeah it's a book they're
doing a big movie
put you in the irishman nobody
i didn't even read for the irishman did
you no they didn't they
did i was overlooked so uh but you're in
saints in new york right newark right
yes but no green book did you read for
the green book
no i know nikki but you were in green
book too no no i know nikki but he
didn't put me in green book i didn't
read foreign nikki said it was tough but
talk to me about
uh now i'm gonna ask you questions talk
to me about
what you did in saints in newark would
you play
i can't you know i can't say the [__]
i'm the rat i can't say so you're not a
rat
you can't tell us what character you
played no i came we had to sign stuff
you know the deal
well i know little [__] because the kid
who plays little [__] but come to my
acting classes
great great kid sampson and john he's
the one that turned me on to you
it was samson who told me you had the
class oh
because she was coming to class with a
little yeah
okay and then the other person is john
um mcgarrell mcgat mcgarro he's in the
saint sinuous he plays silvio
as he were young and i just did a movie
with him um
called birthday cake so he got a lot of
up and coming actors uh playing the kids
and then you got
uh then you got jimmy's kid jimmy's kid
you got ray
you got john bernthal who did a [__]
great job
alessandro who i had on the podcast last
week
you know great people i learned from
some uh i learned some great stuff on
that movie
vinnie yeah who uh when's it coming out
september 24th well that's smart because
they
they're waiting for everything to die
down absolutely absolutely you know
what's crazy
let me tell you the real story so when i
started acting
i booked on my own i booked a pilot i
booked a movie called basketball
and then yeah okay and then i went like
a little bit of a cold streak
i had to do a bunch of college films
which is okay
i didn't know what i was doing as an
actor so i started doing a lot of
low-budget movies
a lot of uh college movies you know [__]
that people won't see
yeah but that's how you learn that's how
you learn i must have done a year of
that
and then the sopranos was coming out
and i came to new york and and i had
reels i had put together reels
and my manager called me and he goes
drop one off at global
drop one off on another company and drop
one off at sheila
jaffe's office because they're looking
for
this thing for the sopranos i dropped
off the other two tapes i never dropped
off the soprano tape i'm like
i can't sing oh oh yeah because
uh stupid you you thought it was uh an
opera some [__] yeah
so i'm not going over there i forgot all
about it
a year later i'm in cleveland and i'm
watching this mob movie on tv and i'm
like this is what i read for
i was supposed to read for holy [__]
then i went back that summer to
caroline's
and the girl saw me the assistant to
sheila
to georgina walking and she saw me that
night at the toyota comedy festival and
she goes
can you come in and read that was for
the second season so i read for the
fbi agent i read for gigi
i read for baccala i read for producers
on all of them but i was too green
i was shaking my sheets were shaking in
front of david chase
i was too [__] green yeah and then
years later they contacted me because i
kept in touch with george ann
anytime i booked something i would send
her a reel of it anything mafia related
once i got analyzed that i sent to the
real
and then she called me in to play your
brother
for four episodes this was after you
were gone already
yeah and i had i was working on
spider-man 2
at sony and they contacted me and they
said we want you to put this
audition on tape for the sopranos i said
absolutely
they go can we fax you the sides i go
listen
don't fax me the sides because i'm not
home i need to press that button
when when you're home to get the facts
sent it to the comedy store so i had
them send it to the comedy store
they sent sides for me and they sent
sides for a comedian named da marrera do
you know what that is
you know dom he's a friend of mine great
guy uh so
without me knowing one of the waitresses
called spoke to somebody at the sopranos
just
off like the way i'm talking to you and
said you know joey diaz and don herrera
are reading for the sopranos that was
like on a tuesday night
on a friday night i get a call from
george anne walken
telling me that i got fired because
the material went out i told somebody
that i was revised one out
and the sides went i didn't show them to
anybody yeah but it went to the comedy
club
i see what's going on yeah so you got
fired
you got fired before you got hired i got
fired before i got hired
well that's not a bad story because you
still ended up in the saints in newark
so they probably still loved you
yeah but it was different casting for
the saints in newark
oh who did the cast oh dug about
i think so i think so i don't remember
offhand
and uh you know i don't want to get you
in trouble with david chase because i
know how david is
um but did you um audition for a
particular role or did they offer you
something no i auditioned for a
particular role yeah
and they called like a week later okay
all right so i guess i can't ask you if
you're dead
no it was great i tell you
working with him was great for me
vinnie i needed that no of course you do
what happens just like anything else in
in entertainment you got to take the
gambles you got to step
up like this whole pandemic has been
driving me nuts
but i learned to readjust my life i put
i got a couple of computers in my office
uh i've been working on stuff a lot you
know um
i'm starting to break out now i'm
starting to book my band again
uh me and johnny got our podcast and
please
come on and do our thing we would love
to have you mean goodbye johnny
we're going up to second year so i'm
trying to stay um
relevant and sharp absolutely
now what are they telling you about the
theater space when are you allowed to go
back there september
no you can go you mean the school yes
the school is we're going to reopen in
the fall
uh but a lot of off-broadway stuff is
opening up in other words if there's a
300-seater
then maybe you can sell 150 seats so
it's all coming back but there's no you
know you know there's no money in
uh theater no no no but you learn
you learn you know so if you've got time
and you want to
you know start working on rec vm and
stuff like that
you start working on it in classes or on
zoom and stuff
but the the best way is to get work
like um let's come on chris chris
maloney's got a new hit show what's it
called
law and order organized crime yeah come
on you don't belong on that
did you go in for it you don't belong on
that
i asked you a [__] question did you
go in for it
no i'm wait me neither i don't they
don't look
you know why they don't think they want
maybe they want people that
are not recognizing but my friend john
bianco's on
i saw chaz on it chad was good he was
smart he got killed in the first episode
that's the only person i saw on it now
you could go back to work on
um another show um godfather holland
uh cathy not gucci's on that mr
you know i'm going to tell you something
joey because i'm on the new york local
and i'm on the national board with st
actress and the work is coming back to
new york
is it really yeah i got to put an
audition on tape for what's his name
today for uh a uh
woody harrelson movie
justin trudeau movie okay you should be
done with people
why not because they're all going to try
to get
this they all of a sudden 100 people
know right now they're going to go now
you've got 101 odds
no but they're looking for a specific
type of looking for cubans
really yeah i'm a [__] cuban
cuban talk to me you know i was watching
andy garcia on tv last night you should
have them on your podcast
he's a tough nut to crack oh he's got a
new television show coming out
does he yeah he's got a new movie coming
out so i was going to talk to him on the
new movie
they're redoing uh fucko's movie steve
martin
the daddy when he when he marries the
father of the bride
yeah they're doing it with the cuban
family so i'm expecting a call for that
oh you got to get on that as a cuban
uncle you know something the [__]
crazy cuban uncle
so once i talk to andy on that maybe
i'll have him on the podcast and talk
some [__] you know
andy's a good person eddie garcia i was
watching my godfather uh three this
morning
how young he was yes yeah he was yeah he
played vincent
but um yeah new york is the work is
coming back i'm a little happy i haven't
been
the lyft job i had was for um nbc for
new year's eve
it was a comedy skit with that amber
ruffin i have no work
no i don't care i thought you were doing
a movie with paulie walnuts up in new
york
state i don't know what happened to that
yeah something because i saw the the the
write-up on it
a lot of projects that they try to get
going because of colvin
then they didn't get the green light
because they got all these regulations
and
insurance things they got to go through
so the independents are getting hurt
in other words me and you do an
independent let's say we got 300 000
budget we got to add on at least another
20 000
for the covert issues and then we got to
get health insurance and all this stuff
so it's bringing in uh another 20 on top
of the budget so a lot of the guys are
getting hurt
see the big budget like i was i was
watching al sapienza
he was he showed how he was on the set
of this new uh i saw that after that
yeah did you see that
yeah yeah but you see a little budget
can't afford to do that no
no and that i got my shot did you get
your shot
you know i'm good man well you want to
make out i'm good but what i'm saying is
what's great about it is that now you
could go on the set
and feel a little better like when i
shot saints
we had to add extra scenes so we had a
shoot in september covert was still out
and i got to see what the work was like
and how much went into it you know the
food that gets shipped on set now
there's you know what a lot of people
didn't know was that sat
this is what i didn't like vinnie this
is what i wasn't happy with
colvin's a disease that's taking lives
you know
whatever you believe whatever so
if you're doing a movie you got to be
extra [__] careful
i heard that sag correct me if i'm wrong
you know you're on the board you're more
involved with that i heard that sag
sent an email to actors that made less
than 7
000 a year 8 000 a year
saying that they were looking for onset
personnel as covet agents
and all they had to do was go online
read for two or three hours this is what
i heard i don't know how true it is
what do you mean by coping agents do you
mean the guy that works on the set to
make sure everything's okay
right yeah i kind of believe in that i
had a covert guy
on each set they gotta have somebody
there and i can't be an actor it can't
be production
no but i this is what i heard i heard
they were getting actors
and using them training them like
making them read three pages making them
take a quiz
and then they were like listen meet
producers meet actors meet directors
this is a perfect job for you and now
they made them covet agents i didn't
like that
i wanted somebody who knew at least
[__] have a nurse so i could feel
confident
oh so what they did was they got three
angry women
three of the angriest women in the world
because they're the only ones that could
pull this off a guy can't come up to you
and go hey
get the [__] away from vinnie but a
woman could come up to you and say hey
get the [__] away from him and
it's okay so you gotta get three angry
women
and one nurse and you feel better i feel
better but if you're just gonna put
regular people there as covert agents
it's not gonna help anybody no so that's
why i've been a little
i don't know if hesitant true but if
it's true
you're giving union actors some kind of
a job because
we're hurting man i mean the extras out
there are
hurting there's no extra work and
they're gonna be no extra work for a
while you can't do
like i was doing wu-tang last year you
know the wu-tang clan
and um you had a lot of extras you can't
do that this year
you can't do a concert scene with the
wu-tang clan everybody going like you
know
you can't you know you can't
those things are man yeah it's going to
change everything and how everything
works for a while
and my main business is stand up vinnie
you know and that's
yeah but the stand up you can make money
because i you know
like listen johnny my guy goomba
you don't go by johnny yes he's running
around with
um anthony rodia
and they're running all over and that i
said how you play these venues he said
vinnie
they do social distance you don't even
meet the audience
no no but you've got to be very careful
because sometimes i got a meet and greet
in june down at wildwood and i told the
guy setting it up
listen i don't care if i got the shots i
don't know about these people who are
going to come to see me
they could take a picture but it's got
to be socially distanced you gotta have
like a backdrop
and nobody's gonna complain
they're not gonna complain i don't wanna
get sick you wanna get sick i don't
wanna get sick
with my business i don't wanna do
stand-up i was doing stand-up vinny i
was trying to be standard i had to do a
stand-up
every week but then there was about
there where the waitress got it
the owner got it people and i had
reconstructive knee
surgery i also got knee surgery in
january
yeah so i'm trying to mend this so yeah
i got my shot last week with my luck
it's [__] jonathan johnson
why what's the matter with johnson
johnson ah they say it's causing
[__] blood clots and women that
killed six women or something oh god
hold on i gotta die right now hold on
i know come on
so we can't walk out of the house stop
did you do johnson johnson
i did jonathan johnson so i'm not
worried about blood clots
all right the bite my experience
but when i went to get my shot i
probably could have picked that call
with just being there
why was that you're playing everybody
was on top of
each other and you know their first shot
was okay the second
shot was a mess
i i was telling the girl sitting next to
me i said we're gonna catch cover just
by being here
there was a lot of people there it was
all backed up it was crazy at the
beginning
yeah my buddy said that where he's going
it's a [__] two-hour wait today
where in north jersey
really they called them yesterday told
them it's a two to two and a half hour
wait so
well you know what tell him it's gonna
be worth it because i tell you what i
feel better and i encourage everybody to
go out there to get the shots you feel
better
you feel like you move around it's like
they said to me
uh do you want to start doing some
podcasts in person do you want your
guests in person
and i said now i want them to zoom in
until everybody feels safe
but they're actually trying to encourage
us to stop moving around joey
well i'm going to move into a different
studio and i'm going to have guests
then you know yeah but i'm going to try
to zoom it
for a while yeah yeah this is out of my
house now
i don't want nobody coming over to the
house you know what i'm saying oh
no this is good nobody coming up with
that
what's good about this you can get the
rock zooming in from hawaii
yeah it don't matter this is good
this is good you watch the late night
shows
they're still zooming everybody in
because everybody's doing it
right right you know and you said
something at the beginning of this and
it was funny
because it is true i owe you money and i
owe you friendship
because you don't know you know money
and you are my friend joey i don't know
enough these kids don't like this to me
andrew you got to go on joey diochai i
said joey's my boy
stop you know i said i love joey see you
know what we gotta do we gotta get
talk somebody into doing something with
being you
some kind of a funny show
you know like we're brothers we play
brothers
there's something like you're right
something we play with brothers
you know we got to come up with
something think about it i mean you're
funny i'm funny
i'm not as funny as you you're a funny
guy
funny huh and then you know you do
something like maybe
um i don't know we gotta write something
and then we film it and you've got and
you've got a little pilot
it'd be funny like something where like
i'm a wise guy and then you come over to
live with me or some [__] i don't want
you in my house
you know maybe you just got into jail i
don't know something funny
can i just be cuban and maybe you don't
like cubans
no you're my brother you play italian
you're not going to play
cuban i want to do a wise guy thing with
you
okay well you want to do cuban why could
i have a cuban
brother i don't know maybe yeah i got to
be cuban why do i got to be cuban
you could be italian you could be a
[__] italian but i'm saying half an
hour
maybe that's why i don't like you maybe
you have cubans this is what we'll do
we're brothers andy garcia
we were brothers but we had a different
father yeah that's it
that's it stop writing it do we have the
same last name
no no no we had the same
mother but not the same father and we
met through that [__] dna thing
we met on uh we met on a love connection
no on 23 and me we met on 23andme
they told me i had a brother that we had
a brother
yeah they told me that i had a brother
so it's you and he says he lives in
brooklyn all of a sudden you show up
and all of a sudden i show up and i'm
what am i doing i'm running a nightclub
what am i doing
you're doing what i'm expecting for you
to be playing maracas and [__]
but i walk in and you're playing a card
game and i got to walk up to you and say
hey
i'm you i'm your brother it's my
military man
and i don't want to bother with you get
out of it get ready and you're like get
the [__] out of here my mother only had
one husband you didn't know that
20 years ago when your mother was 18
yeah i don't i don't want to mention
somebody's name on your show
but i have somebody that a friend of
mine that's in that same situation
so that happened it happened back in the
day
where if a wise guy had a gum on the
side
it's like in the godfather three with
sonny's kid with vincent
yeah that was his gum on the side that
wasn't his wife that's why
uh michael takes him in he says you're
with us because he's family
but you could be like that look at this
we're writing their own sitcom right
here on the spot during a [__] zoom
grand uncle joey's joint what do you
want to call it
give me a cuban name irregular brothers
now how do you say brothers in cuba
el mano that's the name of the
show hermanos
wow joey this is a good idea and anybody
listening to the show pitch it joey
we're pitching it it's all over that's
it just say you know we want to put this
together we'll look at some investors
uh you know we want to shoot a pilot and
it's going to be and you know i'm going
to tell you something they're looking
for material like crazy like crazy right
now
they're looking for the next big [__]
movie's coming out that i did
20 years ago that got lost that is
showing up on television
i've seen that too during the end let me
tell you something every night
spider-man 2 is on speaking of grudge
match it's been on every goddamn night
on stars
yeah and taxi's been on every night
because they're trying to blow up queen
latifah
she was shooting uh the equalizer in
newark why don't you get on that
i never got an audition oh you don't
need no dish
just call her up i don't i haven't seen
him in 15 years queen latifah saw queen
latifah last year
at the the vmh awards we did in newark
new jersey where me and drea
and um uh jamie lynn presented
uh uh uh those kids
those kids from jersey the journalists
brothers we gave
we gave them an award it was this good
skit and that's when i saw her
and she's nice she's a good person you
know
maybe i'll say oh no no she's very nice
i did a movie with her and we talked all
day about jersey she was great
and she shoots in newark yeah she shoots
a newer that's what's good there's a lot
of stuff
coming and i'm telling a lot of my up
and coming actors
you don't want to go to california
you're going to stay right here
in fact there was a project i auditioned
for the other day
and they said we are not looking at any
actors
from l.a we just want new york-based
and that's good for us that's good for
us
they don't want to fly people in and
deal with a lot covered stuff
i know what's going on no i got an
audition for california
that i didn't want to read for and and
and i hated it because it was a mobster
roll
and if you went you got it you would
have had to go to california it was
recurring to [__] boot
but it was california it was like five
to six episodes i had to go back and
forth
and i just wasn't in the mood to do it a
lot of people don't want to do that no
more
it's it's it's um you know
it's it's been crazy it's really been
crazy uh that as entertainers
you know we were the first to get hit
economically
we were and it's hard to get back it's
hard for comedians and
actors and musicians to get back um
and you got to be a little selective on
how you get back because we don't want
to get sick
i'm happy that you have you did a
[__] play during the pandemic vinnie
do you know what that's like
yeah but we did it on zoom i'm gonna
send you the link next time you don't
give a [__] if you did it on
a playground just the fact that you did
it
yeah because you man i give you props
you p
you picked up people's morale by doing
this yeah well what happened
and i love uh maureen and steve and
grandson to like my brothers and sisters
i met them on
on sopranos and um i said to maureen
you know i'm going nuts you know we were
talking just like me and you
on zuma she said we should do something
i said
you should do street car man desire
she's i did it years ago i said you
should do it now how i said i'm zoom
i said i'll put a cast together and it
started
uh as like we were just as an idea joey
and now we taped it we taped it the way
we're taping this
we taped it we edited it we got
permission from the union
we got permission from the the tennessee
williams estate
and uh i went like this holy [__] we
pulled it off and now i sit back
and now i'm working with bobby finero on
my
next play uh that we're gonna do on zoom
until the theaters open up that's all
you know once they open up then i don't
have to do the zoom i'll go downtown and
you sell tickets and stuff
but um i'm serious joey i really want
you
to uh have your guy send me your email
okay and then i'm gonna start inviting
you into things
that we do with renegade and i'm gonna
introduce you to everybody
and it doesn't guarantee you a role but
if something comes up
like for instance we just did casting
for richie victoria's new play and i go
to bobby fernando cast it
and i sent him some suggestions and
they're all from people from within the
group
and people that want to work with us you
know i'm not going to ask him
to put somebody in that we never worked
with before it's all it's a click
and you know all the guys you know for
me i wanted to join the theater group
while i was here
i didn't know where i was just waiting
for the the smoke to clear
yeah i want to be a part of a theater
group in a way you know
just so i've never been a part of it
and i love to study it as you know i'm
it's not for money
no no it's not for money it's not
anything it's insane
and it keeps you sharp and you know what
man you work with young kids
and it's [__] great you know you
mentioned uh
finaro the guy that played bobby
no the the kid that from that did newark
with me
he played silvio you said you know john
johnny yeah you know i spent
spending time with john was great during
the movie
he's a [__] crack up you know the
young guys when you work with young guys
even with me with stand-up
yeah when i work with somebody who's 30
they inspire me
yeah i'm not jealous of them i'm not a
bitter old man
i'm pushing them i want them to do
[__] good right you know so
me work i love all that type of stuff
right i can connect with kids and
they'll ask me
you know i know you love it when people
ask you different questions they look up
to you
you're mentoring them you're helping
them out in the theater
you're letting them know it's okay they
people want that and they need that
right now
so that's what i want to be a part of so
yeah
i'll have mike send you my email yeah
i'm going to invite you to
um um like i'm working on a play now uh
on wednesday afternoons
and if i'll send you a link and all you
have to do and i'm going to say to my
actors joey diaz as he's watching us
work today
and that's all you do you sit back like
you know you go like this watch me you
go like this
and you watch so the words in other
words
in other words you're not on camera okay
and you watch us work but
i'll send you the links to to come in
and watch us work and you'll and joey i
don't do this for everybody i do it for
you
because i know you're rich rich
yeah i'm not rich i just love learning
i heard you got a lot of money [__] if i
had a lot of money do you think i'd be
zooming right now
i'd be in portugal right now what do you
want to do in portugal
from there listen i was talking to
somebody the other day and they said to
me
what would you do if somebody gave you
100 million like they gave you a pal joe
rogan
and i said first thing i would do is
pack my [__] bags
and move to spain
and i would go to and then i would buy a
[__] villa in italy
and i would go to italy on the weekends
just to eat like a [__] doctor
so i could eat like a doctor on the
weekends and i could eat like a doctor
during the week in spain
i would go to england i would get a
podcast studio and i would interview
people in [__] england that's what i
would do if somebody gave me a hundred
million dollars
why you could do it on less than that
i don't give a [__] if somebody gave me
that type of money i'd be out of this
[__] country
well what if somebody's listening to the
podcast say vinnie and joey i want to do
your sitcom but we're going to shoot it
in naples
done in a heartbeat all right okay so
let them know that we're willing to
travel
right [__] yeah right i don't want to go
like to vietnam a place like that no no
hummus i don't want to go where there's
no hummus i don't like hummus
no no i don't like [__] a lot of food
so the foods got to be [__]
uh acceptable you know me i'm picky i
went to jamaica i saw skinny chickens i
was on the next plane
i don't deal i don't want to eat skinny
chickens i want my chickens to have
steroids
i want them to get kicked in the head a
couple times i want them to be in a cage
i'm one of those [__] i'm picky
about food
so if we go to italy we're good
we're good joey joey listen listen we
we're forming something here right now
we're gonna put our heads together
and you watch when people watch this
show they're gonna say you know vinnie
and joey can be great on a sitcom let's
create a sitcom for that
but i think you're right i'm playing
cards and you show up when i say who are
you
and you sound your brother 23 of me
okay that's a great idea so okay
so um our mother had an affair with a
[__]
cuban dude and you're like how dare you
talk to me like that my mother was with
my father for 40 years
right that's that's that exactly that's
exactly
my mother didn't even like my music you
can't tell me about what you did at st
you can't even give me a character's
name nothing
what did you say i signed my life away
it's better that i don't get in trouble
just watch the movie um in fact when
they show it i'll probably take you with
me
and we'll watch it together and you can
give me notes on my [__] acting how's
that
david's gonna invite me to the premiere
what are you talking about
okay so we'll be there soon together
samson
okay when he was shooting he should go
hang out with grinney
okay good good and this kid called me up
nikki nikki you gave my number
somebody gave my number i didn't give
him my i didn't give me your number
nikki i think nikki lip gave him my love
to kid my number and then he came to
class and i just talked to him yesterday
how's he doing samson he's down in
arizona he lives in texas oh in texas
he's down in texas now where does he
live
i thought he moved somewhere because he
was born in l.a
what was going on something like
wherever he was living so he either went
to arizona to texas
i'm not sure oh i i don't know but
where's he from original
i think he's from california
i'll give him a call tonight and check
up on him he called me a few weeks ago
to check in he's a good did you ever
have him on your show
no no no no no i don't want to steal
my id you just see my idea but you
should have uh just reported sopranos
things
to see yeah you should have john
on yes you should have uh uh
tony soprano michael on you should have
all the kids on
yeah john's coming on i'm gonna have uh
john bernthal come on really well you
know
from grudge match yeah i met him i met
him a little before grudge match we have
a mutual friend
yeah so he was always very good to me
but listen
i know you had a a prior appointment and
i don't want to keep you from it i want
to thank you because
because of you you opened up the door
for me
and i always wanted you to do a podcast
because
after you went on the sopranos i booked
more jobs than i could even [__]
handle
yeah i can imagine so uh yeah
so thank you very much joey what are you
saying
what i'm saying is that you opened up
the door for joey diaz to get a bunch
more
italian roles and whatnot and i want to
thank you for that
well joey i love you um uh
talk to uh coming on our show as soon as
possible
we start taping uh next week come on
uh let's start doing some stuff together
you know why i'm going to tell you
something i'm not going to make you
feel sad we got through this
yes we did you know you're talking to me
about
shots and stuff we lost a lot of our
friends joseph arrow just passed away
from the sopranos the other day he was
not called he was very good actor
uh we got through this and i think the
best thing to do
is uh just to start doing things
together why not
what are we selfish we can't help each
other out what kind of a world is that
you know so i'm happy i had this
conversation with you because now
i was telling my wife i needed to do
something else to fill the void left by
stand up
and this will be it i'll have to start
you send me your email i'm not going to
say it again send me your links i'm
going to start inviting you to our stuff
but it's up to you joey to put the time
in the effort
it's just like anything like bruce lee
is sitting in back here bruce lee would
have never been bruce lee if he didn't
put the work in
that's a beautiful way i love you vinny
thank you very much for taking the time
to come on today
how do students get onto your acting
class if they want to join
well my next workshop is all filled up
i had 22 spots and we just filled up
today
and then i think i may have one more but
then i'm going to go in person and when
i go in person starting in september
that's when you you get out of your
house you come through the tunnel
you come sit in my class you sit there
and you observe and i'm gonna say ladies
and gentlemen my guest today is joey
diaz and you ask the actors
questions that's what i want you to
start doing okay
done i love you guys i don't tell people
they're going to do things with me and
then i change my
my you know my mind i'm not like that
you know i know
and i believe in friendship and you and
i are friends
and i love you and good luck with your
podcast and if you don't come on my pod
podcast now
i'm coming over to your house and i'm
going to shoot your dog good
i'm coming on in two weeks i love you
vinny take
good care of yourself you look good god
bless you thank you joey you look good
too all right thank you you got it all
right bye i love you
bye bye buddy
all right you [__] i hope you
enjoyed that you see that it was a great
little podcast a great little zoom
we talked about me [__] going to his
acting classes we [__] pitched the
show right on the [__] podcast
hopefully somebody of interest will be
watching it we gave you a [__] idea
those are models and there you go that's
wednesday's podcast and that's another
episode of the joint
down the [__] tubes whether you like
it or not that's up to you
i'm just happy that you're here have a
great weekend
uh i'm happy you enjoyed your 4 20. i'm
happy you enjoyed the podcast this week
have a great week and we'll be back
[__] monday the last week of april
steaming right through into [__]
maycock [__]
don't forget the ufc on saturday it's
going to be great don't forget to use
draftkings i love you [__] stay
black
have a great weekend see you monday all
right thank you for watching me and
vinnie today it was a great little
[__] time uh like i said in the
wrapper but anyway
the joint is brought to you by express
vpn listen to me with expressvpn you can
trick the computer into thinking
you're in a different [__] world
you'll be able to watch just about
anything
in the [__] world that's out there
you already know that a vpn will protect
your privacy online
but it's taken my [__] tv watching
game to the next level
especially for my wife she unlocked
movies and tv shows
that only available in other countries
like bbc
youtube amazon netflix it works on any
[__] service
and let me tell you something there's a
reason why you gotta express vpn
i can't tell you on the podcast because
they'll throw me under the [__] jail
but you can figure it out on your own
don't be [__] stupid an expressvpn is
ridiculously fast
it streams in hd and there's no
buffering and it works for every person
or device in your home it's easiest
price to use
even for a [__] [__] like myself
just put
push one button and change your location
you'll be watching [__]
sons of anarchy and [__] zimbabwe for
all they [__] know you understand me
but use my special link right now
expressvpn.com
joey and you can get an extra three
months for free that's what i'm doing
for you today
i always show up with something better
than [__] gifts i'm not some [__]
savage
support the joint watch what you want
and protect your privacy
at expressvpn.com joey
the joint is also brought to you by
manscape
one of my favorite [__] products in
the whole world why
because i take two showers a day i like
my [__] to smell good
and i like my ball sack to smell good
but i want it to look good too
if your [__] [__] looks like that
dude that paints bob ross
if your dick looks like that then you
got [__] problem you shouldn't have a
[__]
a [__] afro on your [__] dick you
understand me you got to trim that [__]
down
women are sucking your pipe and they
smell that it smells like a [__] gyro
do you want your balls to smell like a
gyro
be like your uncle joey i'm a fat [__]
but my balls are clean
and [__] beautiful they smell
magnifique
thanks to [__] manscape why because
you got to
turn it up with the perfect package it
features the longbow a 3.0
the best criminal to man it's a third
generation [__] trim this is science
working for you
you ever go to trim your [__] nut
sack you [__] pray to god please i
don't cut my dick off
it's our biggest [__] fear but it's
over with [__] manscape why because
they have advanced giving
safe technology that won't nick or snag
your [__] nut sack
and you got to get the [__] complete
package the complete performance package
you're like joy why
why because you get the crop preserve it
you get the crop reviver
and you get to get the crop ball ball
wipes okay these are here right here
you put those in your wallet just in
case you bump into a [__]
look it's one ph balanced wipe these are
tremendous
and you can see i'm all out of the
revival because i'm trying to revive my
nuts at [__] 58
but they're sending me a new package we
got a new surprise coming for you
[__]
and now you can smell as good as your
balls with that cologne called refined
which is in the bathroom i use that too
because gentlemen prefer smooth balls so
right now today you need to get the
performance package it's wednesday it's
a beautiful day to be alive
go to manscape.com joey right now right
now i'm gonna give you 20
off and free shipping nobody treats your
balls as good as manscape does take
advantage of this
why have an ugly dick and an ugly ball
sack and then you're like no girls stick
around
well take a look at your dick in your
nut sack take a look
whiff with your nut sack if it smells
like [__] sauerkraut you got a
[__] problem my friend
so go to manscape.com joey i want to
thank manscape
and i want to thank expressvpn i want to
thank you guys
for watching and supporting the podcast
every [__] week
i want to thank vinnie pastor for coming
on and
that's it and that's that it's wednesday
i'm still [__] coming down from last
night
and that's all i need to tell you have a
great week thank you for listening
and stay black
[Music]
it's over it's like one of those magic
[__] tricks
foreign
so
you